brittany griner strode into a moscow
court on thursday her latest step on an
odyssey through the russian judicial
system with no clear end in sight state
media reported the american basketball
star will be detained at least another
two months furthering fear she's become
a political prisoner well i'm terrified
i think we all should be very concerned
about brittany griner's safety and all
the hostages who are being held in
russia it's unclear exactly when the 31
year old was arrested but it was first
reported last month as tensions between
the kremlin and the west escalated in
the run-up to russia's invasion of
ukraine
this video was released of griner at the
moscow airport having her bag searched
by federal agents who say they found
vape cartridges containing hash oil an
offense that in russia could carry a
10-year prison sentence
she's not stupid you just don't know
what to believe there's so many
different things you don't know what's
true what's false but i just can't
believe she would knowingly
carry illegal drugs
in a carry-on bag
at an airport griner is no stranger to
russia and its laws having played in the
country the past seven years during the
wnba off-season the u.s state department
has had a do not travel advisory for
russia since 2020. what we haven't seen
yet is any explicit indication that the
case is being politicized
the danger that's lurking here of course
is uh that some kind of hostage
diplomacy situation uh might take place
uh given the the very poor state of
relations between the u.s and russia
right now fear of stoking russian anger
could be why those closest to the case
have said little most notably griner's
wife who has pleaded for privacy as they
work to get her home mike relay global
news toronto